when you got animal crackers you don't
have to do anything you just eat your
animal crackers that's life
hey everyone my name is Matt bellows I
and this is wide about it a weekly video
series where I get drunk at my desk and
complain about stuff and on this week's
very special episode reasons growing up
is the worst
brought to you by Universal Pictures
sisters sisters grown-up parties suck
free slicking because growing up is
basically one long painful reminder that
you'll never be a kid again and life is
a meaningless downward spiral of
responsibility and despair but let's
drink oh good okay there we go okay
that's it all right first of all growing
up means that every time you eat like
you live in a crusty garbage can you
feel like your crusty garbage can you
just see when I really what when you're
a kid I could shove an entire 18-inch
calzone down my throat and [ __ ]
hula-hoop for hours but now when I shove
an entire 18-inch calzone down my throat
I'm disgusting an immature and too old
to be going to the hospital for things
like this every week obviously my love
for calzones next grown up hangovers
hangovers when you're young are just
like soft gentle goose feather pillow
fights just gently rubbing against your
face skin but grownup hangovers are like
if a bear came into your bedroom while
you're sleeping it just ripped off your
scalp a little bigger even angrier bear
comes in and joins the first bear just
knowing on your worthless alcohol ridden
brain also grown-up parties are the
freakin worst oh it's a dinner party you
have to wear a bow tie talk about khaki
pants
and carry a briefcase gah kids parties
are the [ __ ] [ __ ] I want to eat cake
I want to drink juice and I want to
scream the lyrics to I want it that way
until I pass out to a pile of my own
sugary vomit also I would like to ride a
pony if a pony were to be available to
me is a pretty pony named Philippe
Philippe the pony next grown up means
that one day you wake up and you're
tired and that's it you're just tired
forever you just keep being tired until
you die and the only thing that makes
you feel awake is cupcakes we just never
stop eating cupcakes you'll be awake
forever you'll probably die in like a
week but what a week next making friends
is when you're a kid all you got to do
is walk up to someone so you like their
light-up shoes and then BAM you're
splitting a pack of starbursts behind
the jungle gym you're an adult what are
you supposed to do what am I supposed to
tell you about my hobbies and interests
please Spencer go go down to the Tennis
Club play play [ __ ] chess no I'd
never do that because you're awful you
know all grown-ups are awful I don't
want to be friends with you next eating
ice cream isn't even fun anymore when
you're old when you're a grown-up eating
ice cream is just the thing you do to
stay busy while you cry also when you're
grown up everything you do to have fun
costs money
when I was a kid $5 could last me the
whole day a month now $5 can't buy me
[ __ ] $5 could buy me what just one big
old meatball what good is that gonna do
me that'll keep me busy for like 15
minutes and then what and finally being
a grown-up means you suddenly have a
whole bunch of responsibilities that you
never have before everybody is always
yelling at you
do something you can't just sit on your
couch in Spiderman underwear and drink
chocolate milk and yell at a cartoon
sponge well guess what I don't give a
flapping about being an adult and I will
drink my chocolate milk and I will wear
my Spiderman underwear
and I will scream at whatever cartoon
sponge I want to scream at until the day
I die
that is the truth alright everybody
thank you for watching this very special
episode of whine about it as always you
can find our videos every week on
whineaboutit.tumblr.com in my page which
is facebook.com/buzzfeedmatt and you
find our videos on youtube on BuzzFeed
video that's it that's everything
Lancel
spicy no thank you
and no thank you burger it's not today
not today